Okay.
Yeah.
Hello.
One second, I was... I had...
I was doing some stuff on my interface earlier.
And so, my settings are a little different.
Okay.
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello.
Welcome back to HoloCure.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I got new monitors today.
They came in.
I ordered them the other day.
Because they were on sale for Black Friday.
And...
And I...
I...
Now have 4K.
I didn't have 4K before.
Now I have 4K.
And now I can fit the game...
And chat on the same monitor.
Yeah.
Congrats on your nomination.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, yes.
Yes, you guys, I got nominated.
Oh, sorry.
I got nominated for the VTuber Awards.
I'm...
The category is...
Little lady or...
It's...
Girl.
What's the category?
Miss VTuber.
Yeah!
I don't know what that means.
I don't know.
Nominated for being cute.
You can blame my mama.
It means you're a little lady.
Why isn't it the little lady category then?
Miss VTuber.
What does that mean?
I think there was like a Mr. VTuber.
Today at work I had a call from someone with the surname Kun.
Because of you I had to... Because of me?
What do you mean, me?
What did I do?
I'm just... I guess I'm just...
I love how it's a fashion award category.
And I have won it.
It said, yeah, it was like...
She's dressed.
Yeah, I do have clothes on.
Again.
But yeah, it's so exciting.
Wow, thank you for nominating me.
Not all VTubers can say that.
It's so true.
Thanks for everybody for liking my one outfit.
It's my birthday.
Oh my gosh!
Winter Seder!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Winter Seder.
Thank you.
7 months.
That's cool!
It's the heart hole panties.
Maybe.
But that's like a lack of clothes, right?
One day I'll get a second outfit for real.
One day.
One day I'll get an actual second outfit.
For real.
Not a 1.0, 2.0, 3.0.
An actual second outfit.
I've been teasing you guys for 4... Well, I guess 2.0 was a different outfit.
You know.
So, 4.0.
No!
I believe.
Thank you.
You should believe.
It'll happen.
Hold on.
Let me change something on my chair.
If you had a casual outfit, what would it be like?
Overalls.
I don't know.
Maybe the overalls.
Probably.
I love overalls.
And I like wearing overalls.
Any update on long hair Minto or twin tail Minto?
Um...
Celia said...
End of November, beginning of October... Beginning of December, able to work on it.
So, maybe.
We'll see.
Maybe soon-ish.
What job would your outfit be other than maid?
Cashier, OL, race queen?
Well, it could be cashier maid, or OL maid, or race queen maid.
Or any of those kinds of possibilities.
But I'm always a maid, you know?
I have to always be a maid.
Unless it's like casual clothes, but I'm pretty much always on the job.
Kind of.
A maid-maid.
That's what I am now.
Maid-maid.
Well, I'm a ghost maid-maid.
As some people call me maid-mint.
But that's of my own doing.
I think.
Oh my gosh, yes, I can be grocery worker maid.
Yeah.
Good.
First name maid.
Last name mint.
Bakery maid.
Cyberpunk maid.
Cat maid.
I want cat ears, but I don't think I can put them on.
Right?
Oversized Kermit shirt minto.
Yeah, but I already own that.
I have that for real.
Because if I have cat ears, I think it will...
It'll... my hitaikakushi will block it, right?
It's hard for me to do cat ears.
I don't know how.
Anyways, guys.
We're here.
Holocure.
Oh, let me show you some stuff first.
Let me show you.
Oh, no, no, no.
My guys are exhausted.
I haven't fed them in a long time.
Outfit of a zombie.
Of a zombie?
That was my costume for Halloween.
Man.
Sneaking maid.
French maid.
I feel like I'm more French maid than traditional maid anyway, though.
Currently.
Guys.
I've almost...
Look at this.
I've crafted...
Well, okay.
Do I need to craft these?
Do I have to craft...
Is there an achievement?
I couldn't find one if there was an achievement for creating all the weapons.
No, just the max one?
Okay.
Well, I have them.
Why is there not an achievement for creating all the weapons?
I mean the tools.
Not weapons, sorry.
Why not?
I've spent so hard thinking...
I've spent so long thinking that there would be an achievement.
But there never was one.
And then, for this, the hot babe, I did nothing.
I don't even think I stepped foot over here since last stream.
So, there's that.
Do you have the max prism?
What's the max prism?
Do you try commissions?
I do!
The commissions, like these.
Yeah, I do them sometimes.
When I feel like it.
What's the max prism?
The hololight?
This one?
I haven't made any of these.
Should I?
Should I make this?
Helps on stages.
Well, that's what it says.
7 damage from attacks.
But I want to defeat stage 4 on my own without any...
Without any buffs like this.
Because that's how everybody did it in the old days.
So...
I want to do it on my own with my own merit and skill.
Real and fair.
I mostly just played Minecraft.
I didn't really go here either.
So...
I haven't really done much else.
But that's okay.
Oh!
Turn... Wait.
It's day, but I hear the crickets.
You guys hear that?
Isn't that weird?
Day crickets.
The crickets don't sleep in this game?
Oh my god.
Is this guy dead?
No, cicadas are more like...
How does she get in there?
I want to go hang out with my slaves, but I don't know how.
I don't know how to get inside.
Bloodloss, how are you doing?
How does she get in there?
How did you get in there?
She spawned in there.
I guess she works for me now.
No.
Keep working and I'll feed you.
I only play Minecraft.
And then I also...
So today...
With stage 4...
As you can see, I have not defeated it.
It's so sad.
But I want to defeat it.
And also...
I was thinking of using Kiwawa.
But I need to get her fandom up to Gachikoi fandom.
So I don't know.
Nom, nom, nom.
You've seen the Kiwawa knife?
Oh my gosh, yes!
I messaged her about it actually.
Because I told her that I'm a big fan of...
Anime cutlery and anime bowls.
And I have anime plates and bowls and cups.
And forks and spoons and chopsticks.
So I felt like it was entirely made for me.
I think she loves me or something crazy.
So, yeah.
I haven't ordered it yet, but I'm going to.
I don't really cook.
But I still want the cutting board so bad.
It's so cute.
And the knife is really beautiful.
So, I still want it, but I don't cook.
Maid that can't cook.
Okay you guys, you all have to understand this.
I'm a maid cafe maid.
I'm not like a maid maid.
Like I'm not at some prince's castle or anything like that.
I'm a maid cafe maid.
Where we get the food from the kitchen.
And I give it to the customers and I say, Moe moe kyun and I make it delicious.
That's all I do.
I don't know how to do anything else.
How is it a fake maid?
A maid cafe maid is valid.
Yeah, right?
I have to know how to draw things.
And someone will say, Can you draw me a bunny on my omurice?
And I'll say, Of course, master.
And then I draw it and they'll be like, Wow, it's so cute.
And then we take chukies.
It's like how it is.
You guys wouldn't understand.
I think we should just get into it.
Let's see how far we get.
And how well we do.
And I have my quick dash.
Which I'll try to remember that I have.
And let's just do it.
Let's just get in there.
Yeah.
Slice and dice.
Do you put the fries in the bag?
What does that mean anyway?
What does it mean to put the fries...
Like, I mean...
Like, I know what it means.
Literally, but...
Viewers are reacting to Mint's new maid outfit.
Admiring its design and joking about the impracticality of a maid who can't cook.
Messed up.
Minimum wage worker.
But, like...
Why is that a bad thing?
It's like, oh, you put the fries in the bag.
That means he's a minimum wage worker.
I predict...
First try, win easy.
I don't know.
Don't, don't.
Don't jinx me.
I predict.
What song is this?
I think I want the Whammy Water.
Please marry Mint.
Oh,
identity.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Thank you.
Okay, I want the Whammy Water.
Gosh, I haven't...
That would make sense since this is an ID stage.
I haven't listened to that song in a long while, though.
Upgrade, upgrade, upgrade, upgrade.
Alright, so far.
So, do you do take out and not cook?
No, not fraud!
No, like I said, it's a maid cafe maid.
What do you mean by this?
Not a fraud.
I'm not a fraud.
I'm legitimate.
In my own sense, you know.
Fraud cafe?
No!
I'm gonna get the nurse's horn because I feel we might need it later.
One thing about Kiwawa in this game is I'm not so good with her...
With her...
Special, you know.
Typically, when someone should stick to what they know and stop talking about...
What they don't.
I see.
So they're just like, hey man, just put the fries in the bag.
Hey man, just...
You know.
Stick with the status quo.
Kiwawa in a nurse outfit.
All of Kiwawa's outfits are just...
All of Kiara's outfits are so good.
She keeps getting... She's like a fine wine.
She keeps getting sexier and sexier.
You know.
That's how I think about all my wine.
Oh, my wine's so sexy.
You know.
Okay, one thing I also want to try and do is get the... What is it?
The Kusogaki headband or whatever it's called.
I want that.
And we can increase our attack.
12 hour VOD.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Oh, sorry.
12 hour VOD length restored.
Yes, I saw that.
I gotta delete the other one then.
Shackle's build is really funny.
I thought you meant 12 hour VOD me trying to get through stage 4.
I was like, wait a second.
What do you mean by that?
Yeah, I did see that.
Maybe it just took extra time to process.
I have no idea, man.
So crazy.
YouTube confuses me.
Because it was there and then it was gone and then they were like...
They had to stitch it back together.
It was there.
We know it was there.
Ooh, some wood.
If you were doing stage 4 hard, maybe.
Is it really that difficult?
Guys, did you see that Greed was nerfed?
I did a run with Greed and...
I had super chatotime and Greed earlier...
And I only made like 30,000 coins.
I was so depressed.
I was like, what do you mean?
What do you mean?
Why?
I was so sad.
They nerfed it.
I was getting 100k without trying before.
I know!
And then I saw some people that were just like...
Oh yeah, I used to get 50 million coins each run.
Super easy.
And I'm like, you know what?
That's probably like 1% of players.
That's like 1% of players.
See, this one would be so good.
If we had the Kusogaki.
I'm gonna do it.
I think haste...
I love haste.
I think haste applies to everything.
Because...
Because you can always hit harder if you hit faster.
I used to get a trillion zillion coins each run.
You are the 1%!
Don't be hasty.
Except in this game.
Oh, maybe I should have upgraded there.
Oopsie.
Oh wait, you're not a healer, are you?
What are you doing?
I got otaku!
Increase any healing.
Let's go.
Plan letter.
Guys, if you see the Kusogaki, scream.
Okay?
Let's go with this.
Lucky.
He applies to anybody, I guess.
What did I just grab?
Oh, I grabbed some corn.
Oh my god, this guy is over here healing at the same time.
Yo, chill out man.
Stupid.
I see a bottom right.
Incorrect!
Nope.
We'll do more haste.
Oh my god, you guys.
I had a crazy run earlier.
Where I got two special boxes.
And then, in my lineup, I had the Gorilla's Paw.
And then I had the Super Shadow Time.
And then I got two special boxes.
And one...
They were already in my inventory.
And then I got the special version of the Gorilla's Paw.
And then I got the special version of the Super Shadow Time.
I was like, how is this possible?
I didn't know that if something was in...
If you already had something...
You could get more...
You could get the upgraded version.
Then everyone clapped.
It's a real story!
Why would I make that up?
I clapped in my brain.
And my cats probably clapped for me.
They probably were like, wow, Mito!
You're so good at this game!
Oh, I need to keep running.
Oh my god, money!
Money, Yagoo!
Guys, remember...
Wait, remember...
Wait, remind...
Remember to remind me...
When I get an anvil to upgrade...
Lamy water, okay?
Remember...
Kirito, thanks for a whole month.
I'm gonna get some nightly milk.
I like the milk.
Oh, the milk.
Oh, just a tall glass of milk.
Oh, so yummy, so fresh.
What do I need to remind you again?
Uh...
It's fine, I got it.
Don't worry your pretty little head about it, okay?
So far, so good, guys.
So far, so good.
Good collabs.
I'm waiting for the book.
But also, what should...
Well, we did...
I didn't do endless for this, so...
We'll get collabs, don't worry.
Actually, I'm a loner.
I'm a lone wolf.
I don't do collabs.
I don't need anybody in my afterlife.
I'm a lone wolf, you know.
What did I just...
What was that?
So far, so much win.
Wow!
Thank you for the pink!
Okay, shadow.
I'll do this.
Please...
I don't know what I want it to...
What?
See?
This is what happened before!
You guys, this is what happened.
I already had the nightly milk and then I get the better nightly milk.
What?
Oh my god, more haste!
I'm invincible.
Wait, don't say that.
I'm jinxing myself.
Everybody clap now!
Upgrade, upgrade.
Enchant.
Nice.
Everybody clap!
Max.
I guess it doesn't mean much anymore, I suppose.
All these buns look like candy cane candies to me.
A little peppermint.
I'm like a regular mint, but she's definitely a peppermint.
Hey, get out of here!
Oh my god, I was stuck on the pole!
I'm just going to keep going with what we got.
She's a bit spicy.
Mints aren't spicy.
What are you talking about spicy?
Don't forget dash.
True!
Thank you for the reminder.
Dash if stuck.
But I was stuck here.
So I couldn't... It was all me.
It was all me!
What's going to happen now?
Come on guys.
Mints are icy.
Icy.
When am I going to get the BL book?
Okay, what's the other...
Wait, what's the...
What's the super collab you can do with the whammy water?
What is that?
Would peppermint be a redhead with freckles?
Wendy's.
I don't know, maybe.
Glowstick.
Alright, maybe we'll do that instead since...
Haste up!
Oh my god.
Let's get haste 100.
Limiter?
No, it's okay.
We got the nightly milk.
So we need the sake and we need the...
Look at my haste!
Oh my gosh, I got a diamond.
No ice?
Glowstick, I got it.
See, I would like to get this, the membership, but I'm afraid if I never get the...
I guess we have a lot of coins, right?
Yeah, I'm gonna hold it.
Okay, let's get it.
Easy.
Take it for now.
We'll get it.
We'll get the Kusogaki.
How is my...Oh, let's enchant this.
Since we're going for...
For survival...
Survival is most important.
What is he doing?
What's the blue?
Haste up!
Oh my god.
No way!
Oh...
More haste!
It might become my downfall, but I don't really care right now.
We are speed.
Keep one slot free.
Oh yeah, I have two slots left.
We'll need one for the sake.
Okay, we need one for Kusogaki and one for sake.
Okay.
Luckily we have greed...
For...
To help against the membership.
Kusogaki.
Yeah, Kiara is really good, I'll be honest.
Oh gosh.
Oh my god.
Sorry, I'm stupid.
Oh gosh, it's a whole time.
Okay, I gotta lock in.
I gotta lock in.
You know what?
Super!
I made it six.
What did we grab?
I'm gonna run over here for a second.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm trying to get rid of some of these guys.
Taking care...
No, no.
If only earlier.
It hurts.
No.
You guys know I need space for your sake.
I guess I can get the sake and then it will use up that spot.
And then maybe we can get the kusogaki, right?
Drop it for the achievement?
I already have the achievement.
If I have it, I wouldn't need the shackles.
What do you mean I don't need the shackles?
We still have... This is hurting our attack a little bit.
Oh wait, for every ten times holo coins are picked, permanently gain one... Okay, nevermind.
Take!
Nevermind!
You're right, we don't need it!
Okay.
Attack by 50%.
Nice.
Strength, baby!
Strength and haste!
Oh yeah!
We are eating good.
Because we are doing the cooking.
We are doing the feasting.
I keep getting stuck on this damn statue.
Where is my dirt?
Guys, I have a confession.
So because...
So I was...
I just got 4K monitors today, right?
And I play this game...
I play this game not on full screen so that I can read chat and everything.
But...
It would be really small.
I didn't know how to change the resolution because the button never worked.
And then I got this computer and it was so tiny.
Like I... Before when I would play on stream, it would be so so small.
But then it was even smaller this time.
And I was like, oh my gosh, I don't think I'm gonna be able to do this.
So I almost had to play super duper tiny like.
But I figured it out.
I googled it.
How to make it so that it's not so small, you know?
I figured it out.
So I spared you guys.
Well, you guys would never have noticed.
But I would have for sure.
I would have been squinting the entire time trying to read everything.
No, the new monitors aren't OLEDs, unfortunately.
There was... So I went...
At Tokyo Game Show, they had a display for Pixio monitors.
And they were so cute.
They had the whole setup.
They have monitors in blue, purple, green or mint.
It was a little more greener than the mint that I would have liked.
But it was so...
It was so... They were so cute.
And I got mine in pink.
I got mine in pink.
Wait.
Where are we at?
Oh wait, I can see it.
Okay, 7.
I'm gonna hold off on this.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Yeah!
And I'm really happy because...
Before, I was...
Let's go, you know what?
Be a book now.
I was having to deal with...
Well, my monitors, one of them was different than the other, so...
Drop.
Take.
No, I'll take it.
So, like, it would...
It was so annoying because one of them, the color was completely off.
I even looked up the monitor and there was like a Reddit thread that was like...
Do not buy this monitor.
The colors on it are terrible.
I wish I had seen that before I got in it.
Okay.
Yeah, we should start eliminating stuff, huh?
Oh, there's another one.
Wow.
No, I couldn't adjust the colors on it.
It was just not great.
But it's okay.
I tried calibrating it manually.
Now they're two of the same monitor, so...
They are...
We're fit to go.
We're good to go.
G to G.
What should I...
Oh, let's go with Psycho Axe because then we can do that collab.
But I'm still getting used to it because the resolution is all different.
Yeah, we're hot to go.
H-O-T-T-O-G.
Hey, chill out, chill out.
Nah, I'm still getting used to it.
I listened to you and Nerissa sing that a lot.
Thanks for listening to it.
Wow!
Guys, I think this might be the furthest I've gotten ever.
If I beat this first try, which I don't think I will, but...
Oh my god.
Okay, that was so...
No, I'm not gonna get the HALU.
In fact, goodbye!
So you guys can all shut up about it.
I'm gonna get rid of the ninja headband.
Disintegrated.
Yes.
Yeah, if I beat this first try, do I just end the stream?
There's another stage after this though, right?
Isn't it the casino or...
Am I crazy?
Do a stage 5.
Okay.
Stage 5.
Who's doing these?
Yo, yo, chill out, chill out.
Who's this?
Hey, all of you!
Where's my mouse?
Oh, there it is.
Chill out!
Oh my god.
Are we ever gonna get the sake?
Ever?
Hopefully one day.
Okay, we're safe.
Safety.
I'm taking damage.
I'm not grazing enough.
Reroll.
I think we'll try... We'll see next one.
I still have other weapons that I can enhance, but I would like to get the super.
Have you done the hard versions of the stages yet?
I've done the hard version of only stage 1.
So, not a ton.
She's that girl.
I'm that girl!
I saw people being like... I posted that on YouTube yesterday.
I was just like, she's that girl.
I didn't really mean anything by it, but I saw some people being like, I don't understand what this means.
Honestly, me neither.
I just feel like that girl.
It's really whatever you feel like with it, you know?
I'm that girl.
See, I want this!
I want the attack multiplied!
We have a good setup going on, but...
It could be better.
I'm a little...
I want the gorilla's paw.
Ban the paw.
No, I won't have... I won't be able to get it, I think.
It's OK.
Let's just keep going with...
OK, you know what?
I'm going to re-roll.
Actually...
Yeah, I'm going to re-roll, because I want to...
One more!
OK, I give up.
You're definitely one of the most girls of all time.
No!
Drop the limiter.
Sorry, everybody.
We're extremely exclusive club now.
We're very picky.
We're extremely picky.
We're very exclusive.
Please, please understand.
I love getting the limiter.
Don't get me wrong.
But we have the nightly milk, which also increases your...
Which also increases your... What's it called?
Your pickup range.
So it's all good.
And this isn't a very big map, so...
Honestly, it's really easy to get stuff.
OK, let's eliminate...
Hope.
Goodbye, hope.
All hope is lost.
Sorry, everybody.
No hope.
Oh, money!
What is this?
Oh my gosh, I completely forgot about stamps.
If the target is defeated within 2 seconds after being hit by this weapon, you have 1% chance to drop a stamp.
Nah, I'm going to go on haste.
Who would Otacon's Hololive Oshi be?
Otacon's Hololive Oshi.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, I just noticed this.
I think
Pekora is a little too...
I think he would want someone really soft.
Like, you know, kind of soft-spoken even.
Maybe Korone.
Maybe Korone, because she...
Plays a bunch of retro games.
Or Ina?
Yeah, someone like Ina, right?
I don't know.
Or Fauna.
Oh!
Everybody loves Fauna.
Yeah, I could definitely see him loving Fauna.
Couldn't you just see him, like...
With a super, like, you know...
But actually, you know what?
Maybe he doesn't want a soft girl.
He fell in love with Sniper Wolf.
Botan?
Because...
She's like...
Well, she is FPS, but...
Kind of, like, tactical.
Oh my gosh, it's getting a little...
Ah!
Dasaki!
We did it!
Oh my gosh.
Am I even gonna get the super collab, though?
So we're already at 18 and a half minutes.
Guys, I don't even know if this might have been a waste of time.
Oh my gosh.
There's also even this one.
This Psycho Axe to give me...
Oh, nice, nice.
Cutting board?
No.
Sure.
Board plus curse?
Is that a...
It binds with curse?
It does?
Oh, ok, nevermind.
Good, good.
Not that I think we'll be able to...
But...
That's ok.
We're grazing, we're grazing.
Toho here.
What if I never knew what...
Oh, come on.
Seriously?
Reroll?
What the hell?
Wait, is sake maxed?
Oh no, we're not level 50 yet.
Risk of rain?
No, this is Galaga.
Sake is maxed.
Oh, ok.
You think love can bloom in a super chat?
I do.
Someone could see your super chat.
Someone in chat would be like, that person is so dedicated.
Wish I had someone like that in my life.
You know?
What is happening?
What's the pink?
What's going on?
You, I see you.
What are you doing to them?
You're making them emit pheromones.
Oh my god, they're too sexy.
Too real.
Oh, knowing Otacon's luck with girls, his oshi would graduate a month after he...
You know, it's funny because I thought aqua earlier.
I was like, aqua would be really good.
I'm gonna use my special because I'm scared right now.
I'm scared!
They're emitting more pheromones!
Wait, is that me emitting the pheromones?
Wait, who's emitting pheromones?
Is it me?
Oh my god!
Guys, we finally got the hammer.
But...
Oh my god.
Oh there it is!
Oh god!
Wait!
Hold on.
Hold!
There we go.
I was like, wait a second.
Hold!
Oh my gosh.
There is so much going on here.
Look at all of them.
So cute.
We're gaming?
We're gaming!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Guys...
What else can we get?
I'll just do the cutting board.
What if I did the Asakoko?
See, I like to get the...
Sausage!
Thanks for the stream!
Oh Fantasy Island.
Bubble Knife!
Ok, let's do 5.
Let's do stage 5.
I don't even need the dash.
Wow, it's so cute.
Oh, they're coming from the ocean!
They're coming from the sea.
Oh god.
It's kind of scary.
What is this?
Oh, critical hit.
Let's just take it.
You meant hard mode 4.
I don't even have it unlocked.
Osubito.
No!
Let's do stage 5.
I believe in Kiwawa!
Oh my god, a whole shark.
Ok.
Locked in, yeah.
This is our first time playing stage 5, guys.
This is my first time even seeing it.
Ah!
We have so much more stream time now to apply Holo Oshis to MGS characters.
I've decided that based on nothing, Blade Wolfs is Kali.
Ok, that's fine.
I don't disagree.
Oh, there's like Indiana Jones going on here.
I don't know if I agree-agree.
Should we go for the same setup as before?
Let's try...
We can do another haste...
And try for the Kusogaki.
But last time, we were like so set.
We were so good.
It's a good thing she's a phoenix.
BL Super Club.
What's that one?
What's the BL Super Club?
I can't remember.
Gorilla Fire Breath?
I don't like that one very much because it's so targeted.
Yeah, I didn't get the question last time.
BL plus Hope Soda.
Oh, what?
I didn't know that was one.
I think Fatman's Oshi would be Takanashi Kiara.
I will not be answering any questions.
Are you basing that assumption on...
Because she owns a fast food restaurant and his name is Fatman.
I'm just...
Oh my god.
Ouchie, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Let's...
Let's go for it.
Hope Soda!
BL Super Club!
Oh my god.
Can we not keep doing this?
Don't forget the axe.
Yeah, we gotta grab it.
What if I just did the Asakoko?
I wanna get... I should've held it.
But the hold only works...
For like, until...
Like, it only works one thing.
You have to grab it the next time.
You know, it's kind of sad.
The ships fire when you walk past them.
Yeah, I've noticed.
I didn't even notice there were ships over there.
That's fun.
What's this?
What's it gonna give me?
Food.
Oh my god.
He's too cool.
Oh my god, he's too chill.
Where did that chill dog come from?
I want it.
Haste.
Fine.
Nice.
How does this keep happening?
You guys, this is actually like the fourth time in a row this has happened to me!
I'm telling you!
I'm telling you, this is the fourth time in a row this has happened to me!
It has to be when they updated the game.
No, I don't know what I see.
Oh, nice BL book.
I wasn't even streaming when it happened before.
I think it's the patch.
I think it's the new update, you know?
Haste.
That might have been stupid, but I don't care.
I don't care.
The Minto luck.
I don't have any of that.
I don't have any luck, you guys.
Kill the pie.
My first time seeing the sausage!
Should I grab it?
What's it good with?
Should enable drop hacks again?
Collabs with BL?
But we are not doing BL, we are doing BL acts.
We are doing BL acts, remember?
Because we are doing the Hope Super Collab.
I've never seen it before.
I'll grab it still though.
I just want to see it.
Where is the sausage?
Sausage.
Nice.
Too many trees.
Axe!
There we go, baby!
Too many... Actually, this is...
Oh my God!
Look at them go!
Crab Rave!
That's so cute.
Nice.
Who's coming down there?
You, you, you!
I'll take you out.
You can't kill yourself.
I'm too fast for you.
Crab Rave.
Oh my gosh, we still have dance... We still have our own skills to level up.
Let's do dancer.
Tiny dancer.
How tall is Kiara?
Make KFP in the chat.
I think we're close to Gachikoi.
I'm not doing anything.
That's not me.
This was happening to me earlier, you guys.
5-5, thank you.
5-5.
5 plus 5 equals 10.
And she's a 10 in my books.
Alright, now we just gotta get the axe in the BL book to max.
I wanna enchant them as well, but, you know...
Kiara is a 10 out of 10.
Also, I was playing the first level...
The first stage of this.
Did they add the little gyruses in to the first stage?
I don't remember them being there before.
Yeah, they did.
Oh my god.
Scared me.
Oh my goodness.
One great thing about Kiara in the game is when she runs around, she regains her health.
And also gains attack.
So that's why you...
A, B, M.
Always be moving.
Actually, A, B, S.
Abs.
Always be schmovin'.
Did you unlock Nerissa or Elizabeth?
They're not in the game.
Not yet.
Oh wow, we have all of these.
That's kind of crazy.
Let's go.
We'll just do the axe and the book at the same time.
Usually I like to focus on one, but...
We can level them up equally.
Stuck on a tree.
See?
Too many trees.
Trees.
Can't even tell who I'm fighting there.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let's grab our shield.
I think that's Max now, maybe.
Just a chill guy.
I didn't even see who that was.
Whose mascot was that?
There's a Nerissa item now though.
Oh, I think I saw that before.
I've seen like the bibu stamp.
I've never had so many super items.
Kay, if you're watching this, I think the game is...
I think the game needs another patch.
I think something's broken.
Did I get increased speed from that?
Holy moly, I'm zoomin'.
I'm zoomin' right now.
I got an axolotl!
Oh my god.
Wait, I've never...
I haven't even fished an axolotl before.
Are you kidding me?
What?
They dropped an axolotl.
I haven't even caught an axolotl before.
No!
Are you kidding me right now?
Oh my god, did someone raid me?
Thank you.
I didn't see who raided me, but thank you for the raid.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
We're currently going through this crazy...
Look at how many super items I have!
What's going on?
This game is nutso.
I'm not hacking.
Or am I?
This is your luck bonus for having Mato soon.
Oh, I get all the luck now so that I...
So actually, I had to call...
Oh, thank you for the gifted, you guys!
I had to call my maintenance.
Because actually, the shower...
Was only putting out scalding hot water.
And so...
I called them to fix it.
Which...
You know.
But, I know she's a roach.
She would be able to...
Survive it, so...
Even if I have kept it, it's like whatever.
But...
Now, it's opposite.
So, even though it said on the hot side...
It says cold.
Even though it says hot, it's actually cold water.
And even if it's cold, it's actually hot water.
Like, what if I just don't tell her that?
What if I...
Hi, Smee!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
What if I just, like, let her...
What if I just let her be a little surprised?
Action.
Oh, tree!
I wish I could cut the trees down.
I wish to become the one slur.
Oh my gosh, it hasn't even been 10 minutes yet.
I'm stressed out a little bit in this stage.
Oh!
Is this our first?
Oh, our second stamp.
I'll take it.
Increase the size.
Shikami-oh!
Welcome to the membership.
Do a BA gacha pull before your luck runs out.
Guys, I've been so busy.
I haven't even played Blue Archive in a minute.
There's been so much prep for the...
for the concert that it's just been...
my focus for everything currently.
Okay, what was I still trying to get?
The kuso gaki, right?
Maybe I don't need the kuso gaki.
Have you looked at the Heaven Burns Red yet?
No, but I want to.
Because...
Konomi is the singing voice for one of the characters.
You're missing out on Made Yuzu.
I already have Made Yuzu from the last time she showed up.
Just making sure.
These guys have guns!
I was wondering who was...
I was wondering who was shooting at me.
Knockback.
No, let's just keep going with the cycle.
But I haven't gotten any anvils to enchant these.
It's kind of frustrating.
I like how they come from the sea.
It's literally like...
She came from the ocean.
They're all...
just their own sort of kaiju.
Good, good.
Alright.
Coming up on 10 minutes.
First boss.
Soon-ish.
I would like to have a super collab...
before then.
Can I super collab with them?
I guess I can, huh?
I guess I can.
You can?
Okay.
That's why Godzilla is in this stage.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
He did what in the black...
Stop.
You might lose the benefits though.
So then, should we collab the sausage...
and the BL book...
and do another super collab?
Maybe we should do another super collab...
so that we don't lose the super collab.
Wait, you won't lose the benefits.
Are we sure?
There's so many people saying one or the other.
You lose the guaranteed crit.
Yeah, see?
Wait, but then some people are saying you lose benefit...
Wait, benefits.
You won't lose.
Someone mentioned Godzilla.
I don't know.
Even K does...
Wait, K is here?
Okay.
I don't know.
I'm scared.
You only lose the crit part, but it's worth.
Trust.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Let's just apply it since we have a free slot.
Rat.
I'm gonna do it on size.
I can cover so much ground now.
Boss incoming!
I wasn't gonna get the super collab anytime soon anyway.
I'm only level 30.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Oh, Birdbrain!
Hello!
Oh my gosh.
Hello everybody!
Thanks for the gifted.
Wow!
You guys were... I saw you guys were playing earlier.
Thank you for the braid!
Hello everybody!
I'm about to do... This is my first time playing stage 5.
I'm about to do the boss fight and I'm scared.
I'm a little frightened.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, but I didn't get to enchant them.
Thanks for the gifted!
Oh my god, there's too many gifted.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
I think I missed one.
Sir Steak.
For justice!
Justice raid!
Look at this, you guys.
I'm having the ultimate streamer luck in this run.
So I'm scared to lose at all.
OK, I'm gonna save.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, I literally said Godzilla earlier.
No way.
No way!
Oh my gosh.
Oh god.
Oh gosh.
OK.
Don't get trapped.
Keep going.
Around.
Circle.
Circular.
OK.
Three super items?
I know, I'm killing it.
I'm killing it right now.
Kiwawa is my strength!
This is why you always play as your Oshi, everybody.
Your Oshi will give you strength!
OK, I don't think I'm ever... It's fine.
I don't know if I'll ever get it.
The anvil.
We're circling!
Yeah!
My Oshi gets nerfed every patch.
Wait, who's... Who?
Gluz, welcome to Mumbo's shop.
Thank you.
One boss down.
Sausage.
What?
What should I collab with the sausage then?
Joshua, thanks for the gift.
What should I gift with this sausage?
The Asakoko tail.
OK.
I'll still grab this though.
I'll still grab it, but I will wait for tail.
I wish it were fluffy tail, but you know...
Beggars cannot be choosers.
What is this?
Oh, Fen!
Cute.
Tears are one of the best single weapons.
Is that true?
Tears are strong.
An idol's tears.
What's that girl's band cry thing?
The yogurt that makes you cry?
I'm stuck on a tree.
I want to become the Onceler.
I want to cut down the trees.
I'm stuck in the trees.
No more trees.
Queens don't cry.
What is... Everything is happening.
What is that from?
There's so many memes that just have shown up.
I mean, that's usually, I guess, how memes work.
They just show up out of nowhere.
I saw one earlier that was like...
It was Dante and Virgil's mom.
And then she's like, devils never cry.
That one.
That one got a good chuckle out of me.
I really like that one.
Fido.
What do you guys think?
Boom or... What's the other one?
What do they say?
Boom or...
Doom.
Boom or Doom.
Not for Kiowa.
Yeah, I think not for her skill.
I agree.
Doom.
You're both my and one of my cats.
Oh geez.
When he had a baby.
Wait, sorry.
Sorry, hold on.
Let me re-read that.
When he was a baby.
I play VTuber streams for him to get used to people voices and he perks up the most when he streams.
Thank you, Trashboat.
Sorry.
Doom.
Does this map have like boxes or anything?
Like little drops that you go pick up somewhere?
I haven't seen one yet.
But I haven't traveled very far.
I got ambushed.
No?
Okay.
Then I will stay in my comfortable area.
Wait, I'm not in my comfortable area.
I'm at the trees.
Wait, let's go down.
Wait, less trees, less trees.
Where's my cursor?
There it is.
Somebody gifted.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
It's like completely flooded my chat for some reason.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, money, Yago.
Let's just keep making things bigger, baby.
Things are...
Look at her attack.
I need more haste.
He's orange and his name is Mango.
Oh gosh, is he crazy?
I've heard that orange cat... Well, I used to have an orange cat, but he was like the most chill cat ever.
But I've heard that orange cats are like always so crazy.
It's a big sword.
Wait, we increased the size.
That's a big sword you got there.
Hey Mint, I'm so excited to see you at the Phantom Thief concert on December 14th in Atlanta with tickets still on sale at the Phantom Thief website.
Does not overlap with Hololive's store.
Yeah!
Thank you, Nano, for purchasing a ticket to come see Doki and I's first ever 3D concert, Phantom Thief, December 14th in Atlanta.
Not at the same weekend as Anime Week in Atlanta, but not affiliated with Anime Week in Atlanta and also not on the same day as Hololive's store.
So you can have a wonderfully jam-packed weekend of VTuber concerts with the Phantom Thief concert and also Hololive's store.
And you can go home feeling so satisfied.
Thanks for helping me shill.
Sorry for being a little shill.
Sorry for...
Sorry.
Okay, we only need 10 more levels.
Or another collab.
Wait, have we gotten the tail yet?
I haven't seen it.
Tail!
Tail, please.
Skipper.
No!
No skipper.
Skipper, skipper.
Reroll?
Alright.
We'll reroll next time.
Oh my gosh!
So cute!
I love when Watame wears those glasses.
They remind me of, like, an office party where, like, the guy who...
Okay, imagine an office party.
And there's, like, always that one guy that is, like, kind of stoic at work.
He's, like, some, like, you know, balding salary man.
But then he puts on those glasses at karaoke and he's just like...
That's what it reminds me of.
Like, someone like that would wear it, you know?
Okay, reroll!
Roll!
Ah, Asakoko!
And it was enchanted.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Easy.
Guys, we only have 6 minutes left.
Chiara is...
Okay, Kay, if you're still here... If you were even here to begin with, I actually didn't see if you were here or not.
If you're here, don't nerf her.
Okay, I don't... Whatever you're seeing right now is...
Whatever you're seeing right now is...
Is an illusion, okay?
Whatever you're seeing right now...
Is all... It's because of my skill.
It has nothing else to do with her, okay?
It's all me.
Okay, so don't touch her, okay?
She has nothing to do with it.
It's all me.
I take the blame.
I take the fall.
Let me play as her always.
I don't remember.
Someone mentioned...
Someone mentioned using Chiara because she was kind of tanky.
And I was like, oh, okay, I'll try.
Oh no, I'm stuck in the trees.
Okay, here we go.
Let's be in the rocks.
She is tanky.
Yeah, so I was just like, oh, I'll try.
Which, I'll be honest, I hadn't played as her very much beforehand.
I think because... I don't know.
I just hadn't played as her very much beforehand.
And then I was playing a lot with Marin.
And so, this is why I believe.
Always play as your Oshi, everybody.
Your Oshi will never let you down.
Your Oshi will grant you strength.
See?
That's why this is all...
This is why it's going so well, everybody.
Because I'm playing as my Oshi and so I'm getting the strength.
Okay, don't nerf her, please!
This is all me!
Someone is shooting at me.
See?
I dodged that myself.
Oh my gosh, I thought that was Gengar for a second.
Greed!
Bitrate in shambles.
Oh no, I'm so sorry.
Okay, we'll nerf her just to spite you.
No!
Swap crit.
Yeah, my crit is not so high.
But also this one.
I have... Oh no, I don't... I had the nurse horns in the last thing.
I don't have a healing.
I don't have a healing anything.
So I don't wanna really get rid of the lifesteal.
Crit up is good if you have hope zone.
True!
Maybe I do size then.
I'm gonna think about it.
I'm gonna rest my eyes.
No, no, sorry.
I'm gonna sleep on it.
Oh gosh, oh my god.
Nice.
Gimme.
I need more Asakusa.
Thank you.
Oh!
You know what?
That's so true.
We're too late game and I'm not doing endless mode everybody.
Chiara is pretty balanced actually.
I think the one who truly needs nerfing is a certain ghost in her 3's.
I haven't nerfed Iris or Mume in the past couple of updates.
I think Chiara is safe.
Thank you!
Yippee!
While the special meter is still charging, increase crit.
Oh my god.
Do we want crit to just be insane?
But also we don't really need the damage of the skill attack I'd say.
Also thanks for the super chat Kay.
Stop it.
Go away.
Get out of here.
I don't know.
Your special is never charging.
That's true.
I don't use it very often.
I don't use it.
I'm so bad about things like...
No.
OK.
And I'll take my money.
Thank you.
We have a life steal!
OK, now...
Swap.
Wait, what did I just do?
Oh.
Strengthen.
There we go everybody.
And that's how you make money.
That's how you do a deal.
That's how you sign the paperwork.
That's how you...
Oh gosh.
That's how you become your own boss, babe.
The greed.
I know it feels a little less exciting getting it now.
What is this?
Wait.
What is it?
Oh wait, it was the... that thing.
I'm gonna grab...
Yeah, it was the gold anvil.
Thank you.
Spider cooking with tears?
There it is.
OK.
Oh my gosh, this is my first time.
Shoot lightning-charged wieners.
That home into targets and summon lightnings to strike them down.
And now we just need the hammer.
And we'll get everything.
You know what?
I'm gonna summon now.
It doesn't do so much here, but it's, you know, a little bit at least.
Actually, that did help a little bit.
Very good.
Where's the wieners?
I don't see it.
Oh, I see it, I see it, I see it.
Oh my gosh, I see the lightning.
It was just too fast.
Guys, our haste is insane, OK?
The wieners were too fast.
Oh, wow.
Spider cooking.
Hey, aunt.
Welcome to my village.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
If anybody is still here that came from the raid, the collab, how was the collab?
Was it fun?
Did you have fun?
It was great?
OK.
What are they playing?
That one game...
What was it called?
Liar's Bar.
Yes.
I was like...
Yeah, I love Liar's Bar.
Let's talk about the membership.
You literally played it.
I know.
I forgot the name of it though.
What are you going to do?
Sue me?
I'm gaming right now.
I don't have time to be thinking about Liar's Bar.
Let's enchant.
What's this?
Get out of my way, please.
Yippee!
I failed.
Thank you for the 20th day.
Guys, this might be my luckiest run ever.
I have to uninstall the game after this.
I have to uninstall the game after this, I think.
I can't keep going like this.
It's unfair.
It's unfair to the average, you know...
To the average player.
To you measly mortals, you know.
Has a 20% bonus crit chance.
Also increases critical hit damage by 30%.
True infinite BL works.
Oh my god, it takes up the whole screen.
It's craziness.
We are close.
We are incoming.
Final boss!
Where is my... There it is.
Oh gosh.
My health.
Not good.
I can't see anything because the BL is taking up so... It's so insane.
Oh god!
I even lowered the opacity right before the stream.
We
are losing big... We are losing mega health.
Oh god.
Oh god, you guys.
Oh god, I need health.
I need health.
Run!
Run, Kiwawa!
Just gather health, Kiwawa!
Oh god.
Guys, this isn't looking so hot.
I'll be honest.
Oh my god.
Don't forget the dash.
Oh yeah, thanks guys.
I did forget I have dash.
I did forget.
It's because, like, it's...
I didn't forget!
Oh god, I'm stuck on a tree!
I'm scared.
OK.
We are alright.
We are OK-ish.
Oh my god.
First!
Stage 4 first try!
Stage 5 first try!
This is my first time ever even playing this stage.
What the heck?
Owl dagger.
A very fast dagger that slashes continuously in front.
Ilfried, thank you!
A weapon to surprise Pekodom.
Kiwawa!
OK, it's about... It's time to turn off the cheat codes I told you about.
Yes, mom.
I knew it!
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, busted!
Hey guys, I'm a ghost.
Wow.
And I didn't even have gachikoi status for that.
Kiwawa the goat.
So I have the hard holo offices, but I don't have the hard anything else.
Should we try going hard?
Unplug the game shark.
If you type Minky at the start screen...
Let's go hard.
Oh my gosh.
Let's try it.
My dash.
OK.
And we're now gachikoi, so...
I'm... My... I'm a little unwell.
I'm so gachikoi, Kiwawa.
I don't typically like characters that I have to focus so much on aiming.
Because I like to kind of just run around.
I'm gonna grab some CEO tears.
Feeling freaky?
Absolutely.
Kiwawa, gachikoi for you.
Let's do... What was it?
Sausage and BL book?
Let's try that now.
I wanna see it.
I didn't need that.
Ian cursed an owl dagger.
Oh, OK.
I did not know that was a thing.
I will try it.
Thank you.
I like Sana and Mumei because of that.
Me too.
And Fauna a lot too.
One thing that I've been trying a lot for has been the achievement where you just stand there, you know?
I'm gonna get the Nurse's Horn because, again, a healing item.
But I cannot...
For the life of me, do it.
The no move one.
I've tried it with Fauna.
I think I'm just dumb.
And then also because I keep failing at it, I don't get any more like...
Like I'll try someone and I don't get any more fandom points.
Actually, I think I have Fauna gachikoi.
I'm not sure.
Anya for it.
Try Anya.
OK.
I'll get her up.
No move with Hachama.
I've also tried Sana with it as well.
I like the sunset version of this map.
It's pretty.
Sausage!
It's making me hungry.
Sausage.
Who's the sausage I referenced to?
A lot of people recommended Fauna.
Subaru.
Subaru played a game.
Sausage Legends.
What is Sausage Legends?
I used to play a sausage game a lot.
I see, I see.
You guys have so much knowledge.
I'll take that carrot.
Sword fighting with sausage.
Guys, I don't...
I don't know what's happening.
Reach 500 pickup!
Oh my god!
I'm not cheating!
I'm not a cheater cheater pumpkin eater.
Well, I am a pumpkin eater.
Checker PC.
I think Mint needs a nerf.
Great resume.
Thank you.
Alexander, thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
This is not referencing Bay's sausage game.
I remember that.
I was still so shocked that they were allowed to play that game.
I was like, how the hell?
Did they get approval for this?
So you lied about unplugging the GameShark?
I can never unplug.
I'm married to the game.
You guys, I'm married to my work.
I can never unplug.
You die in the game.
You die...
Wait, you unplug...
You can unplug the cheats, but you can't unplug the cheater from...
Wait, the game?
Hold on.
You can unplug the game, but you can't unplug the gamer from the game.
Has she even had any run without a super item so far?
I don't think so.
Oh no, I should have done the sword.
Size.
Bigger, bigger, bigger.
Wait, I want to enchant this as well.
Nice.
Bigger.
Bigger, badder, better.
Nailed it.
You get what I'm saying anyway.
You know what I'm talking about.
You know what I'm saying.
Don't act like you don't know.
Haste!
Can you unplug the plug type Asakoko?
Why would you want to?
Unless you're getting a little sore.
It's hard to sit down.
Some say that's the best part.
Unplug?
I wouldn't know.
Wait, really?
Then why do you even plug it in the beginning?
What's that?
More haste.
So you can unplug it.
Oh my god.
I'm trapped.
Sword!
They're going to trap me in.
They're going to trap me in real.
No HALU.
In fact, I deleted it.
No asking for HALU.
Awaken.
No HALU.
Don't even ask.
Don't even ask for Christmas.
You won't get it.
Horde.
I'll take a glow stick.
Guys, that one wasn't a super super.
It was a normal 3-1.
You guys don't get those often?
It came with the version I downloaded.
It said this version for Minto Fantomu use only.
You guys don't have that one?
Okay.
I honestly don't know.
I've heard some people say that...
I don't know if this has been confirmed or not, but if you have OBS open...
It like, something triggers in the game.
And it makes you drop more stuff.
I don't know if that's true or not.
It is true?
Oh, is it cope?
Oh.
I thought...
Wait, what was I combining Owl Dagger with, you guys?
Oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
What was I combining it with?
Ian Curse.
Oh, no!
I messed up.
Guys, I messed up.
I don't have Axe or Ian Curse.
Oopsie.
We'll
be combining.
We'll be combining.
Don't worry, we'll be combining.
Yeah, slots will open up.
Don't worry.
I'm curious.
Oh, it did say what?
It's like a little slash.
Hi.
Can't believe my Oshie is flexing her streamer life.
I honestly don't know what's going on.
But I told you this happened earlier.
I think...
I think there's something actually wrong with my game.
Nice dodge.
Okay.
Okay, take that.
Soon we will get the gold.
Any second now.
Someone who is polite...
There we go.
Legendary sausage.
A continuously spinning sausage.
Spins faster as you move.
Which I do a lot.
Oh my god.
I have to move a lot because of Kiara.
It's kind of really gross looking.
Sorry Shuba.
It's actually kind of hideous.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh god.
It reminds me of those long furbies.
Alright, now we get the curse.
We must be cursed.
Helicopter.
I need more haste.
I need to be the fastest there is.
Keep moving.
I don't stop.
I literally just keep moving.
I don't stop moving.
Yeah, we need candy.
We need nightly milk.
We need...
I don't stop moving.
You can't make me.
I needed...
What else?
Curse!
That's what I needed.
Alright guys.
Lucky, lucky.
Wait, what was that?
What did I pick up?
It's not weird.
They are often shaped like this.
Oh god.
Easy.
Easy peasy, everybody.
Close.
Dare I say, Kiara may be the greatest of all time.
Fastest ghost in the web.
Don't you know it?
Let's do enchant.
Enchant.
The normal boxes almost seem odd.
Don't say that!
Is there an endless hard mode?
I haven't tried.
There is.
Yeah.
I don't feel ready for it.
I'm scared.
Tears.
What is this?
Sure.
We can try and get more stamps, right?
Alright, everybody die.
Everybody drop dead.
Endless with Halu.
I wish I could have been one of the crazies that...
Got a million...
In one try.
Oh god.
What the?
I killed him so fast.
Sorry, 30 million.
Sorry to... I didn't mean to...
To minimize your achievements or anything like that.
I'm so sorry.
Dival... No!
More owl.
I can't even see the owl dagger.
Like, I don't even know what it looks like, where it is...
What it's doing...
Like, I just believe that I have it.
But I don't see it at all.
It's just there.
Hello, Mito.
Hello!
Oh, it's a Bebo stamp.
But I can't use this one, because it says while not moving.
And that does not work with our build.
Oh, we're already here!
Oh my god.
We're already here!
OK.
What?
That's right.
That's exactly how it was in the first one.
OK.
We're fine.
Everything is good.
Everything is OK.
OK.
Everything is alright.
Oh my god.
There is so much happening here.
I like the little tears.
Let's get one down.
Let's get like a Chan down or something.
And then we can get...
We can get Mikocchi.
Asakoko inject for real hard mode.
Yeah, but then you get the Kusogaki shackles and it doesn't mean...
It's all good.
It's so easy.
You know?
You get the Kusogaki shackles and then everything is fine.
Piece of 8 Chan down.
Why do I keep getting the good Will's pill?
I don't need it.
Drop.
Not this time.
Yeah!
Alright.
Let me out of my box!
Please, let me in.
Guys, I used up all my...
I used up all my luck...
In the previous game.
I'm telling you.
What is this guy doing?
The other guy is health.
Oh, is this guy buffing them with strength or something?
And this guy is buffing them with...
I don't even know.
He lowers your attack.
He debuffs me!
Not on my watch.
He is going to get sausaged.
He is sausaged.
Oh no!
There are two of them.
Disgusting.
Otaku!
Kimoi!
It's right there.
Injection type Asakoko.
Use dash?
I don't need to.
I haven't had to for...
I haven't had to use dash.
I'm too good.
You guys caused that.
A historically deadly disease that...
Continuously spreads to any target nearby...
Has a very small chance to defeat a target instantly.
Oh my gosh.
It's disgusting.
I've never seen that before.
It's so awful.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, these are the mushrooms.
I was like, what is this?
On the ground.
These are the mushrooms that...
Okay, so it hasn't dropped a single stamp.
Only a bunch of mushrooms.
It's kind of useless maybe.
Oh, just kidding.
It dropped something.
Bigger.
Big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big.
Big, big, big, big, big, big, big.
Look at the size of that thing.
What should we collab?
I guess whatever with glow stick?
We've gotten barely any items.
We've gotten barely any items, man.
All weapons.
No defense.
All attack.
Oh, wait.
Fanbeam.
Oh, hold on.
Fanbeam and glow stick.
Oh, I can do fanbeam for either of these.
Let's get it.
Alright.
13 minutes.
Oh, slow, slow, slow, slow.
Oh, speaking of slow, slow, slow.
We'll go towards a big, big, big, big, big, big.
We're the biggest there ever was.
I'm... I'm... Lady VTuber.
What was the category again?
Lady VTuber.
After using special, gain a 25 second buff that increases the damage of all ranged and multi shot.
I'm OK.
Madam VTuber.
I'm Madam VTuber.
Miss VTuber.
Maybe.
If you vote for me.
I think getting nominated is enough though.
I gotta vote for...
I think Kiara is also up for it though.
After all of this... I mean I was gonna vote for her anyway, but after all of this...
I have to vote for Kiara.
There's no way.
There's no way that I can't not vote for her, you know.
No, slow.
Slow, slow.
Super chat time.
Oh, but I must resist.
IDK how to vote.
I think you go to the VTuber reward site and then you...
Google... I don't... Actually, I don't know actually.
You have to log in to your Google account?
Maybe I think...
I'm not quite...
Yeah, your Google account.
OK.
I thought so.
Come here.
I will... Oh, I will super.
I mean, not super.
I will...
Special.
Imagine if you and Kiara end up one vote off and it was your vote for her that makes her win it.
That would be so romantic.
Greed.
Goodbye greed.
We're not doing money run this time.
It's survival, baby.
It's all about survival.
The nightly milk!
Why did I think that nightly milk also did...
Also did...
Haste.
Am I crazy?
I'm so slow!
Screw these guys, man.
They're throwing off my vibes.
Another one.
Get all these kimo otaku out of here.
Who even invited you?
Which one should I do, you guys?
We can do either one with the fan beam.
Which one?
Oh, because I always get super.
Tears?
Tear, tear, tear.
Stream of tears!
Nothing can stop the stream of tears.
Is that it?
It's just spinning around.
We gotta get more haste.
We need candy.
Alright, next time we see a baby, we're stealing candy from them.
Oh my gosh.
Have you guys... Did you know...
Okay, there's one part in the...
What's it called?
In the Charlie and the Chocolate Factory movie.
Where... Oh my god!
Where the guy is singing the song, the Candyman song.
And there's this little girl.
He opens up a counter to let the children in too.
I guess behind the shop.
I don't know why he's giving away candy for free.
But letting poor Charlie...
Stand outside hungry.
He doesn't get any free candy because he's poor.
It's so sad.
But anyway.
And the new one or old one?
The old one!
And he's like making all the candy go everywhere.
And he opens up the counter for the children to run by.
But there's a little girl right in front of the counter.
And her chin is like right above the counter top.
And it's one of those counter tops that you like lift up.
It's one of those counter tops you gotta lift up, right?
Reroll?
OK.
For whammy, someone said?
Oh yeah, we can do whammy.
And...
You just watch her head go...
Right?
I guess they couldn't do it.
Oh my god.
Guys...
Am I gonna live?
Oh, I lived.
I don't know how.
I don't know how I lived, but...
But yeah, it's so funny.
They were just like, yeah.
She was such a trooper about it.
She took it like a champ.
And then went and got her candy.
I don't remember that part.
It's like very...
If you...
It's kind of one of those things where it's like you have to notice it.
If you don't notice it, like you're not gonna see it.
Kind of...
Kind of a...
Oh my goodness.
Situation.
Nice.
Whammy.
Babycore, thanks for the gifted.
Like the stormtrooper hitting their head.
Wait, I don't know that one.
Like there's probably such funny things in the backgrounds of movies.
I also discovered a movie the other day called...
Pup Star?
I think.
Do you guys know that movie, Pup Star?
Apparently there's like five of them.
But the way they make the dogs sing.
It's about like singing dogs.
I didn't know that Air Bud...
Like, you know the Air Bud movies?
They now are like a company that make these really...
Strange...
Like dog movies.
Babycore, thanks for the gifted.
Wait, did I say that already?
Well, anyway, thank you.
I'm losing track because I'm like talking and playing at the same time.
But...
If I could just show you guys how goofy these dogs look while singing.
I guess things got to them after Air Buddies succeeded.
Air Buddies.
All the talking animal movies.
Yeah, they've like done I guess a ton of like talking animals.
But Air Bud never...
Actually, I don't think I've ever watched Air Bud.
But I don't think he talked in it.
He just played basketball, right?
He was just the b-ball dog.
I don't think he talked.
Oh gosh, I'm just gonna run.
I'm just gonna run.
Nevermind.
Knockback.
I'm gonna swap out.
Shoot.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you guys.
I'm gonna die.
Run, run, run, Kiwawa.
Run, run, run.
Get out of here.
Oh my gosh.
Oh gosh.
I'm gonna die.
Just run.
Just run till we find food or your health gets better.
Just keep going, Kiwawa.
Just keep going.
I don't even know what's over there.
I don't even care.
We just gotta get out.
No.
Other way.
I wasn't ready, you guys.
I wasn't ready.
I wasn't prepared.
I was a fool.
OK, our health is getting better though.
Our health is getting better though.
What the hell are these?
What the hell are those?
And dash.
Nice.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no, Toho.
No, Toho.
OK.
Alright.
We're doing OK.
We're doing alright.
Oh gosh.
Cell.
No, Toho.
Oh come on.
What spell card is this?
Maybe I should have gone with the nightly milk actually.
Now that I think about it.
Dang it.
I went the wrong way.
I tried.
Oh my god.
Get me out.
Maybe we can freeze her.
OK.
Oh, I'm not...
I just got this monitor.
I can't.
Oh my god.
Actually, swap.
We'll go with more attack.
We'll kill her.
Kill her with kindness.
And my sword.
Kill, kill.
I mean, we're saving.
We're saving her.
We're saving her, you guys.
Oh, ouch, ouch.
We're saving her.
Oh my god.
Oh my goodness.
It's these ones that always get me.
If only I could...
If only I could shift and see my hitbox.
Properly grazed.
She's still frozen.
Bolt?
Oh yeah, I have that.
Maybe I should've saved it.
But there's all these guys coming in.
It's kind of craziness right now.
Oh god.
OK, hold on.
You guys stay away.
And how about...
I just keep running.
And we'll eventually kill.
Oh my god.
We'll eventually get it.
Right?
Yeah.
Come on!
I'm afraid to die in-game.
I'm already dead.
I'm a ghost, but in-game...
I wanna win!
Oh my god.
It's too craziness over there.
I don't even think I'm hitting her.
Because I'm too far away.
I hit her sometimes.
Why'd you wait your ult to be too bad?
Because I got nervous.
Let's see.
Let's do Uber Sheep.
I don't know actually about...
It's too far away from her.
Please!
Well, we're back at the beginning.
Maybe?
Oh my gosh.
Good.
So many heals.
Uber Sheep.
So close.
NT.
NT, NT.
Look at the screen though.
The screen is ridiculous.
That's why you fight the boss.
Yeah, that's why you fight the boss instead of running away from the boss.
How dare you run when you...
Oh, so you wanted me to die faster is what you're saying.
Because, you know, I wouldn't be able to dodge those.
That's why you, like...
Run.
Instead of...
I mean, wait.
That's why you fight instead of run.
That's what you sound like right now.
Oh, I got something though.
Corporation Pin.
Every 40% of pickup radius also increases attack area of all weapons by 2%.
Nice.
Wawa Super lets you revive while it's active if you die.
Oh, I didn't know that.
I don't... Was it charged?
Like, I don't know.
I have to look back.
I'll just be honest.
I never died as Kiara, so...
Kiwa was so strong.
Yeah, I'm just that good.
I'm sorry you had to know that because you died so many times using her.
But, for me, that was the first time me dying with Kiara.
Because I'm just that good, you know.
No sense worrying over shoulda, coulda.
Yeah, exactly.
I just...
I just win.
Each time, so...
I never concern myself with having to revive.
Guys,
it's a bit of a shorter stream.
But I think I'm gonna call it there.
I completed what I was gonna do, which is kind of crazy.
Actually, before we do that...
Oh, wait.
I should have just started at the casino.
It's so you can fearlessly charge in our amazing, trailblazing Phoenix Oshi Takanashi Kiara.
Exactly!
Yeah!
Let's go gambling.
How
much money do I have?
Perfect.
Let's do it all on the slots, baby.
Slots.
Spain.
Win!
I'm gonna make it big here.
And I'm gonna...
Make...
I'm gonna win jackpot.
And I'm gonna...
I'm gonna be able to buy a monkey!
Win!
It's a win.
I've basically made my money back at this point, OK?
It's fever time!
Fever time!
Minigame?
Oh my god.
Metal Gear has trained me!
I made my money back!
I want the monkey.
I want the monkey!
Give me the monkey!
Guys, I'm actually in a profit right now.
I'm actually in a profit right now.
Show me the monkey.
I'm like so close to buying him.
When do I stop playing the game?
I found some Metal Gear Solid 1999 action figures at my workplace's donation box!
I just thought of you when I saw them because damn, I didn't think they existed until now.
Yeah!
We have to win the 777.
That's the big jackpot.
If I stop playing, does it go away, the jackpot?
No?
Oh, so I can come back to it.
Yeah, I don't have any...
If they're the atomic violent ones, they're kind of ugly so I don't own any of them.
But it is fun to see them.
We'll get the bonus game!
No one stopped before the jackpot.
Yeah, we have to get the jackpot.
We have to get the jackpot.
We have to.
I thought you meant Seth MacFarlane.
That's the guy that made...
This family guy, right?
Yeah, the Tom MacFarlane games...
Toys, especially the Metal Gear ones, I see a solid snake and I'm like, who the hell is that?
I was doing so well earlier!
Look guys!
We're making a profit!
It might be hard to see, because you guys are blocking it.
But we started at 9,000!
I'm at 12,000!
I might be the greatest gambler of all time!
The house hates me!
We're also super brittle and easy to break.
I'm glad I don't own any of them.
Got my solid snake action figure signed at MGSCon.
Wow!
Metal Gear Solid Fan Convention.
Moving to Ontario Convention Center.
Who's Kickstarter?
You can support now.
Yes!
And if you support the Kickstarter, there is a stretch goal of having me be one of the hosts.
That could potentially happen.
And wouldn't it be cool for me to be a part of a Metal Gear thing and I could be like, hey guys...
I talked to David Hitter and he was like, cool hosting!
Five hundred!
Win a monkey with this one weird trick.
The house hates her.
I'm so close to the 7, 7, 7.
My, what's it called, started getting stuck.
My space bar.
Guys, 13!
Holy shit.
Am I actually...
I'm not used to this feeling of winning money in the gamble.
Is this actually how...
Oh, so close!
Oh my god.
This is actually how it feels to win the money in the gamble.
I commented some tips on the last Holocue stream, but it seems like you're doing pretty good.
Try buying some of the weapon limiters though.
It's good.
You think so?
Also, thanks for the tips!
Use mouse click instead.
Should I just turbo it?
Should I get my cookie clicker clicker?
Yeah, most people lose in real life gambling.
But guys, we're making a profit here.
The slots might be the way to go.
I was faster with my keyboard.
In fact, Amito was trying to buy a fucking monkey.
Only losers win in real... I mean, lose in real life gambling.
We're at 15,000!
How is this possible?
I've always lost money in any gambling I've done.
But today...
So if I leave...
And then I do it again...
Oh, it's still there!
Auto clickers work fine with this game?
Let's go.
Okay, hold on.
Let's go to some poor sap...
And rock, paper, scissor them.
Who do you think we should rock, paper, scissor?
Maybe Callie over here.
While she's distracted with the slots, right?
Wait, can I?
Callie.
Callie, no, I don't want to do the slots.
Callie, I want to fight you.
Come here.
Please.
Bay?
I didn't see her.
Takamori fight.
Oh, come here.
No, no, no.
She's too busy with the slots.
You guys keep saying Bay, but she's not here.
You guys are hallucinating.
You're just like...
Bay!
No, she's not here, you guys.
Take your medicine.
Take your meds.
She's not here.
She's never been here.
Let's do... Let's do Ollie.
Scissor!
Rock!
How much am I betting here?
Wait, how much... How much is she gonna take if I... If I lose?
All of it?
She only took 200.
You guys said all, you liars.
I was ready to lose it all.
I was ready to lose it all!
Wait, how much is the monkey?
I'm ready to buy my monkey now.
Actually, I kind of want the beetle.
Wait, you can get trails too!
The sparkles are so cute!
Okay guys, which trails should we get?
The hearts?
The sakura?
The sparkles?
The leaves?
Which one?
Which one should we get?
Mint leaves?
I don't think that's what they are.
I feel like sparkle would be suiting for anybody, you know?
Sparkle?
I see a lot of sparkle.
Bye, bye, bye.
Hold on, I wanna go see it.
Okay, I'm just gonna join again.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh wait, no, no, no, not the house.
Not the house.
Play.
Oh
my god, they are so cute!
Oh wait, she has the trail behind her, so it's kind of...
It looks like the fire is on... The fire is beautiful!
We beautified the fire!
If we had gotten the leaves, they would have just caught it on fire, you know?
Very cute.
Alrighty guys, thank you for streaming today.
I hope you had fun.
My luck was kind of insane in those first two rounds.
I can't believe I beat stage 4 and stage 5.
First try for both of them.
That's so awesome for us.
And we were so close to beating stage 2 hard.
Next time.
Next time, next time.
I've cleared all of these.
Almost all of these with Kimawa now.
A poem with Mata tomorrow?
I won't!
If I stream tomorrow, it will be just me probably, but maybe like Matara in the background.
Or something.
I don't know quite yet what we're gonna do.
But I wouldn't... I don't know if we are gonna... Or rather if I am gonna stream just because...
Like I said, we might go out.
I might go show her some stuff, you know?
Like, show her around the maid cafe and the area and, you know, stuff before things are closed for Thanksgiving.
So yeah.
But we do have an off collab on Friday, so...
Yeah, yeah.
We do have an off collab on Friday, so you will... You can watch that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Excited for P.T.
Stop!
Oh my gosh, I'm so mad.
I'm so mad.
I was just like...
On our off collab, I kind of want Matara to play P.T.
except she plays this time.
I'm gonna talk to her about it.
Because she originally wanted to do... Or rather she talked about wanting to do the patchy slot, but...
It will be spoilers for her and I don't want her to see anything.
So I was just like... I'm gonna make her play P.T.
Because she... Because she has always wanted to play P.T.
And so I was like, well, I have it.
And so she could play it.
And then... And then...
You guys have to go and guess all my plans.
Why are you mad?
I... I...
I'm getting rid of the music.
It makes me sound too happy.
No!
Do you see the anger in my eyes?
Stop spoiling my plans!
Stop!
Let me... Let me have fun!
Let me plan things.
Let me plan things for you guys.
And let me be able to carry them out without you spoiling them for yourselves!
I'm gonna go now.
And I'm gonna go eat jelly to feel better.
Otsumito!
OK, I'm over it.
Bye bye!
Have you considered being less predictable?
I hate you!